[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen meine taten
heute gibt es von mir ein türkisches
video
ich werde doch machen und dieses video
habe ich bereits in meiner alten burgen
gedreht das war irgendwann im herbst ich
habe aber irgendwie vergessen das für
euch zusammen zu schneiden und
hochzuladen
dieses rezept möchte ich euch natürlich
nicht vorenthalten und werde euch
deswegen jetzt auch gleich die zutaten
vorstellen
aber vielleicht vorab ganz kurz sommer
gibt es bei uns in der türkischen küche
eigentlich ziemlich oft es gibt eine
vegetarische variante und eine mit
hackfleisch ich werde heute diese mit
hackfleisch vorstellen dass mit mir
persönlich besser und wir es eigentlich
ziemlich gerne ja und zu den zutaten
geht jetzt sofort
hierfür braucht ihr paprika und zwar
sind es so kleine runde paprika dir zum
beispiel in türkischen supermärkten
findet davon habe ich jetzt acht stück
das sind etwa 800 gramm
es gibt auch kleinere varianten und wer
die nicht möchte kann auch die ganz
normalen roten oder gelben grünen
paprikas nehmen
dann habe ich hackfleisch rinder
hackfleisch 500 kam etwas olivenöl etwa
zwei esslöffel 100 gramm reis
den habe ich jetzt schon gewaschen mit
heißem wasser zwei esslöffel tomatenmark
und ein teelöffel paprika mag eine große
zwiebeln die habe ich schon in kleine
würfel geschnitten
ihr braucht salz und pfeffer und etwas
auch das gute zu passt ist petersilie
die könnt ihr dann auch klein hacken die
habe ich jetzt leider nicht und wer will
kann man noch ein paar tomaten mit rein
geben
bei den zutaten können dann natürlich
auch immer variieren mit dem kräutern
mit den gewürzen die ihr da habt ihr
keinen tomatenmark
da habt oder das nicht mögen den paprika
oder
lasst es auch weg ihr könnt zum beispiel
auch frische tomaten in die füllung
eingeben also experimentiert da einfach
nach lust laune und probiert einfach aus
was euch am besten schmeckt ich mag so
gern am liebsten und deswegen sage ich
euch wie ich so meine dome herstellen
zuerst nehmt ihr euch die paprika die
sind jetzt alle schon gewaschen und da
schneidet ihr von oben diesen deckel ab
einmal rundherum und dann nehmen wir den
vorsichtig weg und könnt jetzt hier
dieses kerngehäuse entfernen den deckel
schmeißt ihr nicht weg den brauchen wir
später noch mal zum abdecken
durch leichtes drehen und den rest
klopfe ich jetzt heraus
[Musik]
die könnt ihr dann eigentlich auch schon
hier in euren großen topf einsetzen
dann könnt ihr auch gleich sehen ob alle
reinpassen
die stell dir einfach so hin wie stehen
gleich wenn dann alle drin sind stellte
hier noch alles so rein mit der öffnung
nach oben
dann könnte ich sie später ganz einfach
gefühlen
das stellte dann kurz zur seite und
bereitet so lange die füllung vor für
die füllung nehmen durch das hackfleisch
da kommt dann der reis hat es so er
klebt jetzt sondern noch nass ist vom
waschen dann tomaten und paprika mag die
zwiebel und zwei esslöffel olivenöl oder
geschmacksneutrale etwas fester und etwa
einen teelöffel salz und jetzt nehmen
wir euch nochmal des täters oder eben
nicht kleine tasse und füllt sie bis zur
hälfte mit wasser und das kommt ja auch
noch getragen das wird dann alles
miteinander vermischt
weil ich jetzt keine petersilie hatte
gebe ich hier noch so diese 7
kräutermischung mit rein da ist auch
petersilie drin kerbel den aber des
staates in dem gericht nicht weiter
dann nehmt ihr euch die paprika und gibt
jeweils etwas von der füllung in jede
paprika
[Musik]
sehr viel zu viel
füllung übrig ich hätte als noch locker
drei bis vier paprika damit füllen kann
das ist aber nicht weiter schlimm ihr
könnt nämlich die füllung auch ganz gut
einfrieren und später das nächste mal
benutzten sehr wenig gibt da jetzt noch
jeweils sind tomaten stückchen mit drauf
und stark
jetzt noch die deckel obendrauf ist
einfach den passenden deckel mit
obendrauf geben muss jetzt auch nicht
mehr perfekt passen war sie brauche es
nicht merken welche deckel zu welcher
paprika gehört einfach so ungefähr
dann kommt jetzt einfach noch mal ein
glas wasser mit rein und kleine stegen
als olivenöl und dann kann es auch schon
gekocht werden gibt jetzt noch den
deckel drauf und dann werden die paprika
etwa eine stunde ganz geringer hitze
gegangen
[Musik]
die gefüllten paprika natürlich auch
etwas kürzer krank
ich denke nach halb drei viertel stunde
wird da auch reichen allerdings mag ich
es ganz gern und es ist mein
persönlicher geschmack wenn die paprika
sehr weich sind ich mag die bei diesem
gericht nicht so gern bis west aber wie
gesagt weißt möchte kocht sie vielleicht
nur eine halbe stunde und alle anderen
können sie etwas längere haare
[Musik]
ich hoffe ich konnte euch mit diesem
rezept wieder einen kleinen einblick in
die türkische küche geben wird mich
sondern natürlich über rückmeldungen
freuen und über personen die dieses
gerichte nachkochen und dann freue ich
mich schon auf mein nächstes video freue
mich auf eure kommentare und bewertungen
und verabschiede mich dann bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]